My hands on the humming like it's a mold buried stone. Ask it the oldest questions. It answers and dialogue. St. Sto. And zeros singing in the static when the signal slows. It's cold machine inside this cold. Let it ride these broken roads.
我的双手在嗡嗡作响，仿佛那是埋在土里的模具石。向它询问最古老的问题。它回答并进行对话。圣徒。零在静电中歌唱，当信号变慢时。这寒冷机器内部一片冰冷。让它在这破碎的道路上驰骋。
Hey guys, it's Joel. And welcome back to psychotherapy on the couch, the psychohistory of America. psychology. What psychology can see, what it can't see, and why it has trouble telling the difference until now. This is part nine, the end, the last one. Thank you for bearing with me. So eight episodes of describing how the apparatus got built, why we call it what we call it, why we can't see it, and why it has done the practice of sitting with another human being, I think, a disservice, which is not that hard. That's one of the easier things to do, at least for me. In the last episode, I tried to lay out where the science of the future is pointing,
大家好，我是乔尔。欢迎回到《沙发上的心理治疗》，美国的心理史。心理学。心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么直到现在它都难以区分这两者。这是第九部分，终章，最后一部分。感谢你们的耐心陪伴。前八集描述了这套机制是如何建立的，我们为什么这样称呼它，为什么我们看不见它，以及为什么我认为它对与他人共处的实践造成了损害，这并不难做到。至少对我来说，这是比较容易做到的事情之一。在上一集中，我试图阐述未来科学的指向，
what the science of the past has already told us multiple times, and which information, you know, the clinician as instrument catches as we approach the frontier, because the frontier moves too fast for any manual to capture. Psychology itself may be changing faster than any other point in history. You look at something like Moore's Law that says computing power is going to get pastor. Well, you look at my thesis and other people's thesis from anthropology that we draw different metaphors about the self and psychology and psychopathology and what we are, what we're supposed to be, how we make meaning from technology. Well, Moore's law says it's going to double in speed and increase exponentially. From there, then what does that say about how psychology will
过去科学已经多次告诉我们的内容，以及当你接近前沿时，作为工具的临床医生会捕捉到哪些信息，因为前沿移动得太快，任何手册都无法捕捉。心理学本身的变化速度可能比历史上任何时候都要快。看看摩尔定律，它说计算能力会变得越来越强。嗯，看看我的论文以及其他人关于人类学的论文，我们对自我、心理学、精神病理学以及我们是什么、我们应该是什么、我们如何从技术中创造意义，得出了不同的隐喻。好吧，摩尔定律说它会以指数级速度翻倍增长。从那里开始，这对心理学将如何
change. But hell, maybe I'm wrong. I don't know. And then I guess that question would not be relevant to the future. So how does the field produce a generation of clinicians who can see what is wrong? Who can see and name what is wrong, who have the evidence base, real evidence, to say what is wrong and then change it? Well, that's the question this episode is about. So one thing that we should look at is reverence and the other is complexity. You know, together they form this effective institutional defense system, you know, an egoic type defense, but not an individual in a macro in an American professional life. You know, you can't fix psychiatry or psychology or social work or counseling or any of the free licensed mental health professions until you
改变意味着什么？但见鬼，也许我错了。我不知道。我想那个问题对未来来说可能并不重要。那么，该领域如何培养出一代能够看出问题所在的临床医生呢？谁能看出并指出问题所在，谁拥有证据基础——真正的证据——来说明问题所在并加以改变？嗯，这就是本集要探讨的问题。所以我们应该关注的一点是敬畏，另一点是复杂性。你知道，它们共同构成了一种有效的制度防御系统，你知道，一种自我防御，但不是个人的，而是在宏观的美国职业生活中的。你知道，你无法修复精神病学、心理学、社会工作、咨询或任何获得许可的心理健康专业，直到你
understand how reverence and complexity work together to keep the field unaccountable to the people it claims to serve and to the practitioners it claims to enforce accountability upon. And what I want to put down is, you know, walk through the structural pieces. We already did some of that. But it's not that the apparatus is captured. The apparatus was constituted from its, in its very beginning, a defense against the mystery of psychological work. And it was made that way, not by the smartest people, not by the best people,
理解敬畏和复杂性是如何共同作用，使该领域对其声称服务的人群以及对其声称强制问责的从业者变得不负责任的。我想提出的是，走一遍结构性的部分。我们已经做了一些。但并不是说这套机制被俘获了。这套机制从一开始就是作为对心理工作神秘性的一种防御而构成的。它是那样被制造出来的，不是由最聪明的人，不是由最好的人，
people, not even really by the most influential people, but from the most useful people to it, the ones who could not tolerate the mystery and needed to convert the work into something that could be procedurally administered. They're not really ever the best. Go through the most interesting people in the series or the most interesting people in history. It's not the winners that win. And that is a thesis that I will lightly put down. But, you know, the reference and the complexity that hold the apparatus in place are not just sociological armor in a generic sense. They are institutional expression of a specific psychological problem. The people who built and run the apparatus need psychology to be the kind of thing that it is not.
甚至不是由最有影响力的人，而是由对它最有用的人，那些无法忍受神秘感，需要将工作转化为可以程序化管理的人。他们从来都不是最好的。看看这个系列中最有趣的人，或者历史上最有趣的人。获胜的并不是赢家。这是一个我将轻描淡写提出的论点。但是，你知道，维持这套机制的敬畏和复杂性不仅仅是广义上的社会学盔甲。它们是一个特定心理问题的制度化表现。那些建立并运行这套机制的人需要心理学成为它本不是的那种东西。
And they've spent 100 years rebuilding the field in the image of what they needed it to be, largely because they needed you to be different than I think you are. In the metrics, the manuals, the protocols, the credentialing, the licensure, the evidence base, the entire infrastructure is the externalized form of an internal incapacity on their part. And it is the failure to tolerate mystery scaled into institutional architecture. I'm not even making, you know, big go out and do something. A lot of these people are dead, right? I mean, 100 years old.
他们花了一百年时间，按照他们需要的样子重建了这个领域，很大程度上是因为他们需要你变得与我认为的你不同。在指标、手册、协议、认证、执照、证据基础中，整个基础设施是他们内在无能的外化形式。这是将无法容忍神秘感扩大到制度架构中的失败。我甚至不是在说，你知道，去外面做点什么。这些人很多都已经死了，对吧？我的意思是，一百岁了。
We basically started with the Indians with the series. I'm just asking you to notice patterns in history. And in that, we might notice how to make fail, safes against the psychology of history and the history of psychology to make a better future. But I don't think any of these things go away, no matter what kind of bureaucracy you build. I think you're always going to be noticing human nature and trying to anticipate its worst parts. And when you stop doing that, that's when they won.
我们基本上是从这个系列的印第安人开始的。我只是要求你们注意历史中的模式。在这一点上，我们也许能注意到如何为历史的心理学和心理学的历史建立故障安全机制，以创造一个更好的未来。但我认为，无论你建立什么样的官僚机构，这些东西都不会消失。我认为你总是会注意到人性，并试图预见它最糟糕的部分。而当你停止这样做时，那就是他们赢的时候。
I remember learning about the Holocaust and like ninth grade or something. And they were saying, like, people did this bad thing for no reason. reason and they were just really bad. And then after they were done doing it, it's important that we talk about it so that we make sure that, uh, you know, we know that they did this thing. And that was just kind of the attitude of the teacher in the class. And I was like, wait a minute. No, I think like this is the baseline of what when we slip, we fall onto and we do that over and over again. And so we should be making sure that it doesn't happen again and actively trying to prevent it, not just holding it up as a monument for a bad thing that happened that can never happen again.
我记得在九年级左右学习大屠杀。他们说，人们无缘无故地做了这件坏事。他们只是真的很坏。在他们做完之后，我们谈论它很重要，这样我们就能确保，呃，你知道，我们知道他们做了这件事。这基本上就是老师在课堂上的态度。我当时想，等一下。不，我认为这就像是我们滑倒时跌落的基准，我们一遍又一遍地这样做。所以我们应该确保它不再发生，并积极尝试预防它，而不是仅仅把它作为一个发生过的、永远不会再发生的坏事的纪念碑。
And they were like, yeah, yeah, we should prevent it. But, you know, the point is this is like the worst thing ever. And nothing will ever be that bad. I was like, well, let's go further back. I mean, it's a bad thing. But like doesn't this just seem like the thing that we do that when we stop being able to see it, when we dissociate from our capacity to do it, we are doing it? Or we are not far away from doing it.
他们说，是的，是的，我们应该预防它。但是，你知道，重点是这是有史以来最糟糕的事情。没有什么会比这更糟糕了。我说，好吧，让我们回溯得更远一点。我的意思是，这是一件坏事。但难道这看起来不像我们所做的事情吗？当我们无法再看到它时，当我们与我们做这件事的能力解离时，我们就在做这件事？或者我们离做这件事并不遥远。
And I don't know. They disagreed with me. Then maybe you disagree with me now. But leave that on the table because if you walk into this episode thinking that the problem is bureaucratic drift or capture, you do miss a point that maybe I did make very well. You know, bureaucratic drift can be reformed by better policy. But what we have here is something else. It's a field whose practitioners in disproportionate numbers entered the work because they could not tolerate the mystery. The work is fundamentally constituted by, I think.
我不知道。他们不同意我的观点。也许你现在也不同意我。但把这个问题放在桌面上，因为如果你走进这一集，认为问题是官僚主义的漂移或俘获，你就错过了一个我可能讲得很好的重点。你知道，官僚主义的漂移可以通过更好的政策来改革。但我们这里有别的东西。这是一个领域，其从业者中不成比例的人进入这项工作是因为他们无法忍受神秘感。我认为这项工作从根本上是由此构成的。
And who have built and maintained an institutional structure that allows the work. them to continue working in the field without ever having to solve not the mystery, but the encounter with the mystery. And I mean, psychologists getting in a fight about this thing, I think is an indication of the field doing well when they're all accusing each other of not sitting with the mystery enough or not having, you know, deep enough. Like who is it? Oh, crap.
并且他们建立并维护了一种制度结构，允许他们继续在该领域工作，而无需解决——不是神秘感，而是与神秘感的相遇。我的意思是，心理学家为此争吵，我认为这表明该领域做得很好，当他们都在指责对方没有足够地与神秘感共处，或者没有，你知道，足够深。是谁？哦，该死。
What's his name? The guy who's like almost Carl Jung, but it's backwards. Psychosynthesis. Who is the psychosynthesis guy? Roberto Asajoli, that's it. Yeah, he's like almost Carl Jung, except backwards, because Jung is like, you should analyze the darkness in order to understand it and then fill it up with the light of awareness.
他叫什么名字？那个几乎是卡尔·荣格，但反过来的人。心理综合。谁是心理综合的人？罗伯托·阿萨吉奥利，就是他。是的，他几乎是卡尔·荣格，除了是反过来的，因为荣格说，你应该分析黑暗以理解它，然后用意识的光芒填满它。
And then he's like, no, you just go into the light of awareness. And then it will burn away the darkness. And they, like, kind of make an opposite model. But then they judge each other. And, you know, they're both like, he is not as deep and spiritual as I am because I'm going deeper. I'm being more spiritual. And like, yeah, you know, psychologists fighting in this way 100 years ago is kind of
然后他说，不，你只要进入意识的光芒。然后它就会烧掉黑暗。他们，就像，制造了一个相反的模型。但随后他们互相评判。而且，你知道，他们都说，他没有我那么深刻和精神，因为我钻得更深。我更具灵性。而且，你知道，心理学家在一百年前以这种方式争吵，就像今天一样
insufferable as it is today. But I do think that it is a symptom of a healthy field. Um, because, you know, we're all students in this thing. And when you see, you know, people who are kind of being insufferable in that way in an English department, their freshman year or philosophy department or, you know, and one of those, that attitude, it's not that they're right. It's that they are after something that we've lost. And I kind of miss, you know, those fights. Um, so, you know, the bureaucracy is the symptom, and it is the hungry ghost obsession with the mechanism of action. We have to figure out why it is that the change happens, you know, as this mechanistic variable. And the reverence and the complexity are the symptom.
令人难以忍受。但我确实认为这是健康领域的一个症状。嗯，因为，你知道，我们都是这个领域里的学生。当你看到，你知道，那些在英语系大一或哲学系以那种方式令人难以忍受的人，或者，你知道，在其中之一，那种态度，并不是说他们是对的。而是他们正在追求我们已经失去的东西。我有点怀念，你知道，那些争吵。嗯，所以，你知道，官僚机构是症状，它是对作用机制的饥饿鬼式的痴迷。我们必须弄清楚为什么会发生变化，你知道，作为这个机械变量。而敬畏和复杂性是症状。
And the actual disease is that the people who should be most comfortable with what cannot be measured are by selection and by training, the people least comfortable with it. And they have used their institutional power to make the field unable to admit the unmeasurable. And that is where the work will always happen. And I want to start with something that's been on my mind throughout the whole series, I guess to end with something, which is that the question of like when that capture happened. Because the way that I've been describing it in the previous episodes,
真正的疾病是，那些最应该对无法测量的事物感到舒适的人，通过筛选和训练，却是最不舒适的人。他们利用自己的制度权力使该领域无法承认不可测量的事物。而这正是工作永远会发生的地方。我想从我在整个系列中一直思考的事情开始，我想以某件事结束，那就是关于那种俘获何时发生的问题。因为我在前几集中描述它的方式，
you might come away thinking that the capture happens to clinicians after their licensed or after they join an insurance panel, which in my opinion really doesn't affect much other than, you know, the responsibilities that come with that, but they don't change that many things. or the employers or the regulatory bodies sit with them and pressure them.
你可能会认为俘获发生在临床医生获得执照或加入保险小组之后，在我看来，除了，你知道，随之而来的责任之外，这并没有影响太多，但他们并没有改变太多事情。或者雇主或监管机构与他们坐在一起并向他们施压。
You know, this is an active control. And, I mean, there are institutional rules. Some of them I agree with some of them. I don't, but that's a tiny part of it. You know, it is not where the capture really starts. The capture starts earlier. It starts in training. It starts in the way that the whole thing is framed
你知道，这是一种主动控制。而且，我的意思是，有制度规则。其中一些我同意，一些我不同意，但这只是其中很小的一部分。你知道，这不是俘获真正开始的地方。俘获开始得更早。它始于训练。它始于整个事情被框架化的方式
to somebody who's walking in that is unfamiliar with any of it. And the capture starts when a young doctor, or a social worker or a psychologist is learning day by day, what kinds of explanations they're going to be rewarded for offering, and what kinds of explanations they're going to be punished for offering. And the capture happens in graduate school. The capture happens in residency, and by the time the license clinician walks into their first job, the capture is already done. You are serious if you are this way, and if you are not this way, you are not serious.
对于一个走进来且对这一切都不熟悉的人来说。当一名年轻的医生、社会工作者或心理学家日复一日地学习他们会因为提供什么样的解释而受到奖励，以及因为提供什么样的解释而受到惩罚时，俘获就开始了。俘获发生在研究生院。俘获发生在住院医师实习期间，当获得执照的临床医生走进他们的第一份工作时，俘获已经完成了。如果你是这样的人，你就是认真的；如果你不是这样的人，你就不是认真的。
I'm lucky for me, I thrive on not being taken seriously. I'm a hundred hundred, 100% tricks or archetype. Whenever I detect somebody taking me slightly seriously, I make it as hard for them as possible until it becomes impossible. That may be part of the way that we have to have a passive resistance to a form of passive control, because I don't think that this is active control, and I don't think that there is an active resistance to it that is effective.
幸运的是，我不被认真对待反而茁壮成长。我是百分之百的骗子原型。每当我发现有人稍微认真对待我时，我就尽可能让他们感到困难，直到变得不可能。这可能是我们必须对一种被动控制形式进行消极抵抗的方式的一部分，因为我不认为这是主动控制，我也不认为对此有有效的积极抵抗。
I think it's going to be something that looks and sounds kind of like that. Tanya Lerman, you know, we talked about last time, cultural anthropologist from Stanford. We talked about her watching the hearing voices in people with psychosis being different in first in their world countries. Well, you know, she did another thing that I like, wrote another book that I like. Her book is of two minds. And it's interesting because it's documenting history that I think American psychiatric
我认为它看起来和听起来会有点像那样。坦尼娅·勒曼，你知道，我们上次谈到了，斯坦福大学的文化人类学家。我们谈到了她观察到精神病患者在第一世界国家中听到的声音是不同的。嗯，你知道，她还做了另一件我喜欢的事，写了另一本我喜欢的书。她的书是《两种思想》。这很有趣，因为它记录了我认为美国精神病学
establishment psychology establishment, establishment wanted to ignore and largely did. even though it's sort of a study of, kind of like what I'm doing, he has a study of the psychology of the psychologist by an anthropologist. So, you know, she looked at American psychiatric residents that were arriving at their training programs as young people who are interested in human suffering and how they changed at a specific time in history. And so many of them, you know, have been drawn to psychiatry
机构、心理学机构想要忽略且在很大程度上确实忽略的历史。尽管这有点像我正在做的事情，但他是由人类学家对心理学家的心理学进行的研究。所以，你知道，她观察了美国精神科住院医师，他们作为对人类痛苦感兴趣的年轻人来到培训项目，以及他们在历史上的特定时间是如何改变的。他们中的许多人，你知道，被吸引到精神病学
because they wanted to understand minds and help people. And they arrive with this mix of curiosity, and some are interested in the psychological, and some are interested in the biological, and most are interested in both, and how do they intersect? Where's the meat, meet the soul? And they imagine when they're entering training
是因为他们想了解思想并帮助人们。他们带着好奇心来到这里，有些人对心理学感兴趣，有些人对生物学感兴趣，大多数人对两者都感兴趣，它们是如何交叉的？肉体在哪里，灵魂在哪里？他们想象当他们进入培训时
that they will learn to think across both registers, and they'll become doctors who can hold a patient's biology and biography at the same time. And what happens to them over the four years of residency is that they're forced to, and this is the cohort she's following. I'm not saying that this is my opinion that's happening to doctors. I'm telling you about the book.
他们将学会跨越两个层面思考，他们将成为能够同时保持患者生物学和传记的医生。在四年的住院医师期间，他们身上发生的事情是他们被迫，这是她跟踪的群体。我不是说这是我关于医生身上发生的事情的观点。我是在告诉你关于这本书的事。
But the choice is not made, and thank you, Jason, for telling me about this book, because I did not know about this one. And I appreciate you for that. So there is no moment where a senior faculty member sits down and the resident says, hey, you have to pick a side. They just sort of see these sides emerge. You know, the choice is made by the structure of the training itself. The reward selects through a systemic selection. through where it gives rewards. And she's following a psychiatrist.
但选择并没有做出，谢谢你，杰森，告诉我这本书，因为我不知道这一本。我很感激你。所以没有一个时刻是资深教员坐下来，住院医师说，嘿，你必须选边站。他们只是看到这些立场出现。你知道，选择是由培训本身的结构做出的。奖励通过系统性选择进行筛选。通过它给予奖励的地方。她正在跟踪一位精神科医生。
I believe she starts in 89, but it's largely associated with changes that happened over the course of the 90s. And, you know, she's noticing that rewards are more important than punishments. And I'm reminded of where Sidra Stone in, what is it,
我相信她从89年开始，但这在很大程度上与90年代发生的变化有关。而且，你知道，她注意到奖励比惩罚更重要。我想起了西德拉·斯通在，那是什么，
embracing ourselves, the voice dialogue manual, where him and his wife, Sidra, because they co-wrote it two authors. I don't want to leave one out. said, the people who give us praise judge us much more strong than the people who give us punishment. But she notices that, and she says, by the time the licensed clinician walks into their first job, that captures already finished. But what capture? Psychiatric residency, you know, is organized around rotations, exams, case presentations, and they systematically privilege, she says, one kind of
《拥抱我们自己》，声音对话手册，他和他的妻子西德拉，因为他们共同撰写了它，两位作者。我不想漏掉一个。说，给予我们赞美的人比给予我们惩罚的人更强烈地评判我们。但她注意到了这一点，她说，当获得执照的临床医生走进他们的第一份工作时，俘获已经完成了。但什么俘获？精神科住院医师，你知道，是围绕轮转、考试、病例陈述组织的，他们系统性地偏袒，她说，一种
explanation over the other, depending on the one you get to. The biological explanations are the ones that get rewarded. The psychological explanations get tolerated sometimes, but they're increasingly framed as soft, as unscientific, as sort of a sport that you do when the real work is done, or a sport that you watch when the real work of medication is done. You know, as the sort of thing that a resident might do on the side, once they've mastered the real work of medication management and DSM diagnosis to understand it. And I definitely saw that when I was in the hospital. I think I got shut down almost every time I said anything in a grand rounds to a psychiatrist.
解释优于另一种，取决于你得到的那种。生物学解释是得到奖励的。心理学解释有时会被容忍，但它们越来越多地被框架化为软性的、不科学的、某种在真正工作完成后进行的运动，或者在药物治疗的真正工作完成后观看的运动。你知道，作为住院医师在掌握了药物管理和DSM诊断的真正工作后，可能会在旁边做的事情。当我在医院时，我确实看到了这一点。我想每次我在精神科医生的查房中说任何话时，我几乎每次都被打断。
And we were supposed to talk. But when I would talk, I mean, they would kind of literally roll their eyes and wave their hand because I would say like things like, I remember one time the guy said that patients report liking this and it's fine to do it because it stops them from coming back to the hospital, the psychotherapy technique. But it doesn't work. We know the evidence says it doesn't work. When I raised my hand, I was like, wait, so the patients report the symptom one away and they like it, but they, and they don't come back to the hospital.
我们本应该交谈。但当我说话时，我的意思是，他们会字面上翻白眼并挥手，因为我会说，比如，我记得有一次那个人说患者报告喜欢这个，这样做没问题，因为它阻止了他们回到医院，这是心理治疗技术。但它不起作用。我们知道证据说它不起作用。当我举手时，我说，等等，所以患者报告症状消失了，他们喜欢它，而且他们没有回到医院。
What do you mean it doesn't work? And he said, well, you know, they've tested it and there's no mechanism of action there. And I was like, you mean they don't know what the mechanism of action is? But every time people do it, they get better. They don't have symptoms and they don't come back to the hospital. And he just kind of said, yeah, you could do that as well as you could do anything else. And I wanted to raise my hand again and say, hey, but you mean, if you did something else, though, then that wouldn't work. you're talking about one thing that we know does, but like, anyway, I wasn't that confident or
你是什么意思它不起作用？他说，嗯，你知道，他们测试过它，那里没有作用机制。我说，你的意思是他们不知道作用机制是什么？但每次人们这样做，他们都会好转。他们没有症状，也不会回到医院。他只是说，是的，你可以像做任何其他事情一样做那个。我想再次举手说，嘿，但你的意思是，如果你做了别的事情，那就不起作用了。你在谈论一件我们知道有效的事情，但无论如何，我当时没有那么自信或
antagonistic at that time. But, you know, Lerman says that there's a subtle pressure once you look for it. In the same way that that statement that I repeated doesn't make sense. You know, he was tracking one thing, this guy said out loud, the guy I asked, was tracking one thing. I know that this works based on my huge experience being a psychiatrist for a long time and seeing it done, that it has an effect. But the science tells me it doesn't. So I still have to. kind of shame it as not being valid. Okay. I mean, you're just saying out loud, the science disagrees with my experience, except I will cite against my experience because I have dissociated. That's strange, man. So, you know, Lerman says, you know, these attendings, a lot of times,
对抗。但是，你知道，勒曼说，一旦你寻找它，就会有一种微妙的压力。就像我重复的那句话说不通一样。你知道，他正在追踪一件事，这个家伙大声说出来，我问的那个家伙，正在追踪一件事。我知道这基于我作为精神科医生很长时间并看到它被执行的巨大经验是有效的，它有效果。但科学告诉我它没有。所以我仍然必须，某种程度上羞辱它，认为它不成立。好吧。我的意思是，你只是大声说出来，科学与我的经验不一致，除了我会引用反对我的经验，因为我已经解离了。这很奇怪，伙计。所以，你知道，勒曼说，你知道，这些主治医生，很多时候，
they'll ask, you know, helpfully, what medication are you considering? And then the resident learns every single time they bring up patient's family of origin or history of trauma or the patient's attachment patterns or the patient's symbolic relationships or the way they connect with the patient or the way that, you know, they self-disclose their own suffering and they watch the patient improve. The person will be gently pushed back to medication. Not saying medication doesn't work. Just she's noticing that they're not a little longer interested in these other things in the hospital because the 90s represented a time where psychiatry was being forced to become a procedure instead of a process because we build based on procedures and everyone else could do procedures
他们会很有帮助地问，你正在考虑什么药物？然后住院医师每次提到患者的原生家庭或创伤史或患者的依恋模式或患者的象征性关系或他们与患者联系的方式或他们，你知道，他们自我披露自己的痛苦的方式，并且他们看着患者改善时，就会学到。这个人会被轻轻地推回药物治疗。不是说药物不起作用。只是她注意到他们在医院里不再对这些其他事情感兴趣，因为90年代代表了一个精神病学被迫成为程序而不是过程的时代，因为我们基于程序计费，而其他人可以做程序
faster. And so it was already losing all this money. And they were under all this pressure to keep these psychiatry wings, basically as close to being in the black as they could to keep them open. The managers are going to do that. So over time, the resident learned to present the case the way that the attending wanted to hear it. And, you know, the thing that I did not learn. This is with the doctors that had, you know, granted hundreds of thousands of dollars sunk in an education that they had to pay back. So they learned symptom checklist, they learned DSM differentials, they learned medication responses. The biographical material just gets dropped.
更快。所以它已经损失了所有这些钱。他们承受着所有这些压力，要让这些精神科病房基本上尽可能接近盈利以保持开放。管理者会那样做。所以随着时间的推移，住院医师学会了以主治医生想听的方式陈述病例。而且，你知道，我没有学到的事情。这是与那些，你知道，在教育上投入了数十万美元且必须偿还的医生一起。所以他们学习了症状清单，他们学习了DSM差异，他们学习了药物反应。传记材料只是被丢弃了。
And it's not because the resident has decided that the biographical material doesn't matter. It's because the resident has learned that the biographical material does not get rewarded. And rewards are how training works. I mean, very few times do you get punished in psychology training if you're getting punished you or maybe not going to be working for a while or ever again. So by the end of residency, Lerman says the residents have been formed into a particular kind of doctor, and they can still talk about psychological material if you ask them to. They've just learned that talking about psychological material is something that you do off the clock.
并不是因为住院医师决定传记材料不重要。而是因为住院医师已经了解到传记材料不会得到奖励。而奖励是培训运作的方式。我的意思是，在心理学培训中，你很少受到惩罚，如果你受到惩罚，你可能暂时或永远不会再工作了。所以到住院医师结束时，勒曼说住院医师已经被塑造成一种特定类型的医生，如果你要求他们，他们仍然可以谈论心理材料。他们只是了解到谈论心理材料是你下班后做的事情。
I mean, there were times when I was on, you know, another part of the hospital. I would bring this stuff up when we were deciding on how to intervene, what to do an intervention, pick a mechanism of action. And the psychiatrist would say, that's really interesting. We don't need to talk about it now. I'll talk to you about it, you know, later. And I've got some interesting ideas. Like, what do you mean?
我的意思是，当我在医院的另一部分时，有几次。当我决定如何干预，做什么干预，选择作用机制时，我会提出这些东西。精神科医生会说，这真的很有趣。我们现在不需要谈论它。我稍后会和你谈谈，你知道。我有一些有趣的想法。你是说，什么？
Like, we're literally deciding. Anyway, that's how they work. In private conversations, that's what a lot of the psychiatrists that Tanya Lerman documented are, that's where they're putting this material. And it was also in sort of the cracks of practice, you know, like around the medication prescription, they would keep a patient that they liked longer and they would engage them in these conversations. But like, this is just sort of something that's interesting, not something that's useful.
就像，我们正在字面上决定。无论如何，这就是他们的工作方式。在私人谈话中，这就是坦尼娅·勒曼记录的许多精神科医生所做的，这就是他们放置这些材料的地方。它也存在于实践的裂缝中，你知道，比如在药物处方周围，他们会保留他们喜欢的患者更长时间，并让他们参与这些对话。但是，你知道，这只是某种有趣的事情，而不是有用的事情。
and she sort of saw that as maybe that is the part that's useful. You know, the official practice had become biological in the 90s. We're going to finish the human genome project, and that's going to tell us how these medications work, and then we'll understand why we've been moving in the right direction before we had a reason to. So the unofficial practice, the private practice of paying attention to the actual human being in front of you had been pushed out
她有点认为这也许就是有用的部分。你知道，官方实践在90年代已经变成了生物学。我们将完成人类基因组计划，那将告诉我们这些药物是如何工作的，然后我们将理解为什么我们在有理由之前就一直朝着正确的方向前进。所以非官方实践，即关注你面前实际的人的私人实践，已经被挤出了
of the formal structure of the work. And so notice what is actually being. selected for in a passive process. The residents who are passive incentive, passive motivations. The resident who succeeded in this training, they're not a resident who are the best at integrating biological and psychological thinking. The resident who succeeded are the residents who can tolerate the abandonment of the psychological dimension.
工作的正式结构。所以注意在被动过程中实际被选择的是什么。住院医师是被动激励，被动动机。在这个培训中成功的住院医师，他们不是最擅长整合生物学和心理学思维的住院医师。成功的住院医师是那些能够容忍放弃心理维度的人。
If you're aware of the psychological dimension at all, it's a hindrance to you because it's just dead weight that you're carrying around and thinking about that is not contributing to the process of what we do here. It's like the guy who's always trying to talk about, you know, Chaucer at the work mill. You know, shut up and make the widgets. The person who knows the thing that you know, that knowledge is actually hurting you.
如果你意识到心理维度，它对你来说是一个障碍，因为它只是你随身携带和思考的死重，并没有对我们在这里所做的事情的过程做出贡献。就像那个总是试图谈论，你知道，工作磨坊里的乔叟的人。你知道，闭嘴，制造小部件。那个知道你知道的事情的人，那种知识实际上在伤害你。
You know, when I graduated in the middle of a recession with a comparative religion degree, I would be like, please, for $7 an hour, can I put books on the shelf? And they would be like, oh, you're overqualified. It's just like, you know, literally you're telling you, we don't really want people with these kind of degrees. is there any degree to work here.
你知道，当我以比较宗教学位在经济衰退中毕业时，我会说，拜托，每小时7美元，我可以把书放在架子上吗？他们会说，哦，你资历过高了。这就像，你知道，字面上你在告诉你，我们真的不想要有这些学位的人。这里有任何学位可以工作吗。
You know, the selection pressure is not for skill. The selection pressure is for the capacity to be untroubled by the loss of the dimension of the work that requires tolerance for mystery. And the residents who cannot make this conversion, either leave psychiatry, or they develop the chronic professional unhappiness that I see in mid-career psychiatrists
你知道，选择压力不是为了技能。选择压力是为了能够对失去需要容忍神秘感的工作维度而不感到困扰。而那些无法进行这种转换的住院医师，要么离开精神病学，要么发展出我在职业生涯中期的精神科医生身上看到的慢性职业不快乐
when I talk to them, and sometimes when they listen to this show. Thank you all. You know, the apparatus does not just capture clinicians. It selects across the entire training pipeline for people whose discomfort with mystery is high enough that they will be relieved when it is taken away from them. You know, the people who entered psychiatry because they were drawn to the mystery, either get washed out or get demoted into a private practice where they don't make anything, or they learn to perform the procedural
当我与他们交谈时，有时当他们听这个节目时。谢谢你们所有人。你知道，这套机制不仅仅是俘获临床医生。它在整个培训管道中筛选那些对神秘感的不适感足够高的人，以至于当它被拿走时，他们会感到解脱。你知道，那些进入精神病学是因为他们被神秘感吸引的人，要么被淘汰，要么被降级到私人诊所，在那里他们什么也做不了，或者他们学会了执行程序
identity while keeping the actual work hidden, which I think there's a pretty big school of. It's why I'm not just, I don't think like we're in 1984 of psychology and that no one out there hears this stuff because a lot of people keep the good work hidden or private. We're on the side, you know, at the bar. And the credentialed psychiatric workforce is by construction a workforce whose tolerance for the mystery of psychology has been systematically lowered across years of training. And that's not an accident. This is what the apparatus is for. And here's one thing I want you to continue to notice in these stories, because a lot of these are just stories. You know, it's the central observation that the capture that is happening now today, this year,
身份，同时将实际工作隐藏起来，我认为这有一个相当大的流派。这就是为什么我不仅仅是，我不认为我们处于心理学的1984年，也没有人听到这些东西，因为很多人把好的工作隐藏起来或私下进行。我们在旁边，你知道，在酒吧里。而获得认证的精神科劳动力在结构上是一支对心理学神秘感的容忍度在多年培训中被系统性降低的劳动力。这不是偶然的。这就是这套机制的目的。这是我希望你们在这些故事中继续注意的一件事，因为其中许多只是故事。你知道，核心观察是现在正在发生的俘获，今天，今年，
every psychiatric residency in America is doing it while we're listening to this. In America, they're processing for a cohort of residents through this same pipeline that Lerman documented 25 years ago, except it's different now. The incentive has not changed, but it's faster. And the expectation that we even entertain these things is less. If anything, the mechanism has intensified because the pressure to manage caseloads through medication has only grown, which doesn't mean that it's not needed. But the biographical inquiry has just shrunk, and the cultural authority of any kind of depth
美国的每一个精神科住院医师都在这样做，当我们听这个的时候。在美国，他们正在处理一批住院医师通过勒曼25年前记录的同一管道，只是现在不同了。激励没有改变，但它更快了。我们甚至考虑这些事情的期望更少了。如果有的话，机制已经加强了，因为通过药物管理病例的压力只会增加，这并不意味着它是不需要的。但传记调查已经缩小了，任何形式的深度的文化权威
has waned. And young doctors who entered residency this past summer, you know, 25, hoping to become integrative thinkers about human suffering, are right now being trained out of that hope. And by the time they finish in 29, most of them will have been formed into the kind of doctor the apparatus needs, regardless of what their capacity was to be excellent, or what they wanted when they started, or what they notice, you know, against that system. like the guy who's saying, yeah, we know this works,
已经减弱了。而去年夏天进入住院医师的年轻医生，你知道，25岁，希望成为关于人类痛苦的综合思想家，现在正被训练出那种希望。到29年他们完成时，他们中的大多数人将被塑造成这套机制需要的医生，无论他们成为优秀医生的能力如何，或者他们开始时想要什么，或者他们注意到了什么，你知道，反对那个系统。就像那个说，是的，我们知道这有效，
but we are not allowed to know it. And I'm like, what? And he was mad. Then I pointed out what he said. You know, the same, but he was right that it worked. And that's why he was allowing it to happen as the top guy, you know,
但我们不允许知道它。我说，什么？他很生气。然后我指出了他所说的话。你知道，同样的，但他是对的，它有效。这就是为什么他作为顶尖人物允许它发生，你知道，
or one of the top people. The same thing happens with local variations across the other mental health training pipelines. You know, master's level social workers, they, these programs, they don't produce social workers
或者顶尖人物之一。同样的事情也发生在其他心理健康培训管道的局部变化中。你知道，硕士水平的社会工作者，他们，这些项目，他们不培养社会工作者
who can think across, all these layers that I described in that episode. You know, they produce social workers who can complete a DSM-based assessment and write a treatment plan that meets the insurance company's documentation requirements while still being afraid that they didn't do it right because of the reverence and complexity. The reverence for the complexity. You know, Masters-level counseling programs don't produce counselors who can hold a patient's symbolic life and semantic state at once.
谁能跨越，我在那一集中描述的所有这些层面进行思考。你知道，他们培养的是能够完成基于DSM的评估并编写符合保险公司文档要求的治疗计划的社会工作者，同时仍然担心因为敬畏和复杂性而没有做对。对复杂性的敬畏。你知道，硕士水平的咨询项目不培养能够同时保持患者象征性生活和语义状态的咨询师。
They produce counselors who have memorized the names of evidence-based protocols and can administer them with, I guess, a lack of insecurity. A mechanistic competence. You know, doctoral programs a lot of times don't produce psychologists who can integrate across schools. They produce psychologists who can defend a single methodological orientation through a dissertation and then practice within it. A lot of those guys are really proud that theirs is the best and the others are bad, which cuts you off from a whole lot of knowledge about what.
他们培养的是记住了循证协议名称并能以，我想，缺乏不安全感的方式管理它们的咨询师。一种机械的胜任力。你知道，博士项目很多时候不培养能够跨流派整合的心理学家。他们培养的是能够通过论文捍卫单一方法论取向，然后在其中实践的心理学家。其中许多人真的很自豪他们的最好，而其他的很糟糕，这切断了你对，你知道，什么的大量知识。
what those other fields contain in the Venn diagram between what you do and what they do. Even if they're wrong, you know, one of the authors that I like a lot, and he said, I learned way more from reading bad books because I knew immediately what the lesson was. When I read a good book, I didn't always know what the lesson was. When I read a bad book and I was like, that sucked because of this reason. I knew a new thing not to do. And then I figured out how to solve the problem. When I read a great book, sometimes I was like, that's a fantastic book.
那些其他领域在你的工作和他们的工作之间的维恩图中包含什么。即使他们错了，你知道，我非常喜欢的一位作者，他说，我从阅读糟糕的书中学到的东西比阅读好书多得多，因为我立刻就知道教训是什么。当我读一本好书时，我并不总是知道教训是什么。当我读一本糟糕的书，我当时想，那很烂，因为这个原因。我知道了一个新的不该做的事情。然后我弄清楚了如何解决这个问题。当我读一本伟大的书时，有时我想，那是一本很棒的书。
And I don't really think that I can write like that and that project is finished. When you find something wrong with something, a lot of times that points you to this self-evident, self-evident thing in you that is saying, the world should be different in a way that you notice and you can do. And so that's why I think the history of psychology and all of its weirdness is a lot of fun and also a lot of important lessons. You know, training programs aren't filled with bad people and the training programs are filled, you know, largely with people who themselves have been formed by people. previous iterations of this same pipeline. And the faculty teach what they were taught. The supervisors supervise the way they were supervised. And the whole machine reproduces itself through the slow generational transmission of what kinds of explanations get rewarded. And the accountability for the outcome for whether the clinicians produced by this pipeline
我真的不认为我可以那样写，那个项目完成了。当你发现某件事有问题时，很多时候这会指向你内心那个不言自明的、不言自明的东西，它在说，世界应该以一种你注意到并且你可以做到的方式变得不同。所以这就是为什么我认为心理学的历史及其所有的怪异之处既有很多乐趣，也有很多重要的教训。你知道，培训项目里并没有坏人，培训项目里，你知道，很大程度上是那些本身就被，你知道，这个相同管道的先前迭代的人所塑造的人。教员教他们被教的东西。主管以他们被监督的方式监督。而整个机器通过对什么样的解释得到奖励的缓慢代际传递来复制自身。而对于结果的问责，对于这个管道产生的临床医生
can actually do work anywhere is nowhere. The schools don't have it. The boards don't have it. The accreditation bodies don't have it. The clinicians, once they are out, have all of it. And the patients become less aware of what's missing because it's less common and they don't know what psychology is supposed to do that they don't have. You know, take Aaron Beck, the founder of CBT. You know, he's trained as a Freudian psychoanalyst at the University of Pennsylvania. He came out of that training the way that a lot of the best critics of any tradition come out, which is, you know, he is this true believer who took the tradition seriously
是否真的能在任何地方工作，是无处可寻的。学校没有，委员会没有，认证机构没有。临床医生，一旦他们出来，就拥有了所有这些。而患者变得不太意识到缺少了什么，因为它不太常见，他们不知道心理学应该做什么而他们没有得到。你知道，以CBT的创始人亚伦·贝克为例。你知道，他在宾夕法尼亚大学接受了弗洛伊德精神分析师的培训。他从那种培训中出来的方式，就像任何传统的最好的批评者出来的方式一样，那就是，你知道，他是这个真正的信徒，他认真对待传统
enough to actually test all of its claims. And he was by every account from people who knew him, a careful and curious researcher, not a rebel and not somebody who came in with some axe to grind. He was the kind of clinician who wanted to know whether the model he had been trained in was actually right. He was curious and scientific. So in the 50s and I think into the early 60s even, you know, Beck runs a series of studies on himself on these dreams of depressed patients. He expected, you know, the studies to validate the classical Freudian hypothesis, which is, you know, depression is anger turned inward against the self and the dreams of depressed patients should therefore contain massacist. content, you know, evidence of self-punishment, the libidinal mechanisms of aggression and
足以实际测试其所有的主张。根据认识他的人的每一个说法，他是一位细心且好奇的研究员，不是叛逆者，也不是带着某种斧头来磨的人。他是那种想知道他受过培训的模型是否真的正确的临床医生。他好奇且科学。所以，在50年代，我想甚至进入60年代初，你知道，贝克对自己进行了关于抑郁症患者这些梦的一系列研究。他期望，你知道，这些研究能验证经典的弗洛伊德假设，即，你知道，抑郁症是转向内心的针对自我的愤怒，因此抑郁症患者的梦应该包含受虐狂。内容，你知道，自我惩罚的证据，攻击性的力比多机制和
are being redirected at the ego. And these were case studies that had built American psychoanalysis. But they were case studies. There were things Freud said he found self-evident, not things that data was supporting. And so they thought that there would be this massacistic content in the dream and interpret it, you know, back to the patient and watch depression lift. But the studies didn't show that. You know, dream after dream Beck actually found that the content in depressed patient's dreams was about, I mean, I guess depression, loss, defeat, deprivation, rejection, hopelessness. It wasn't what Freud said would be there, which was, you know, anger and rage about, you know, killing the self through some kind of psychosexual lens. And so the depressed patient in, you know, Beck's samples were not unconsciously punctured.
指向自我。这些案例研究构建了美国精神分析学。但它们终究只是案例研究。弗洛伊德认为这些是显而易见的，而非数据支持的结论。因此，他们认为梦中存在受虐倾向，并将其解释给病人听，希望看到抑郁症好转。但研究并未显示这一点。贝克实际上发现，抑郁症患者梦中的内容大多关于抑郁、失落、失败、匮乏、拒绝和绝望。这并非弗洛伊德所说的通过某种性心理视角表现出的愤怒和狂暴。因此，贝克样本中的抑郁症患者并非在潜意识中自我攻击。
themselves. They were experiencing reality as a series of losses, and their unconscious was processing the losses, not orchestrating some kind of self-attack. And so, you know, this is the moment where Beck did something important. He let the data change his mind. And he did not bend the data back into the existing framework. He did not torture the interpretive, you know, lens to preserve his theory. He'd looked at what was actually happening and said, okay, the patients were processing a view of reality that has been bent in particular ways towards this negative self-image. And the bending happens, you know, in thoughts.
他们将现实体验为一系列的损失，而他们的潜意识在处理这些损失，而不是在策划某种自我攻击。这就是贝克做出重要贡献的时刻。他让数据改变了自己的想法。他没有为了维护现有框架而曲解数据，也没有为了保全理论而强行进行解释。他观察了实际发生的情况，并得出结论：患者处理的是一种以特定方式扭曲为负面自我形象的现实观。而这种扭曲发生在思想中。
So maybe thoughts lead to feelings and feelings lead to behaviors, and we can change thoughts and change the system. So cognitive therapy is born by just sort of bypassing all of Freudian's interpretation. I mean, which I think you rejected them because they're largely wrong. Psychoanalysis doesn't really make a ton of sense until it goes to some of the women and some of the developmental psychology experts, you know, Karen Hornay, I think is in Winnicata are huge. And then it maybe makes a little bit less sense when it gets picked up by French theorists. I don't know what happens to it under Lacan, but.
所以，也许思想导致情绪，情绪导致行为，我们可以通过改变思想来改变整个系统。认知疗法就这样诞生了，它绕过了所有弗洛伊德式的解释。我认为你拒绝这些解释是因为它们大多是错误的。精神分析在引入女性视角和发展心理学专家（如卡伦·霍妮和温尼科特）的观点之前，并没有太多意义。后来被法国理论家接手后，它变得更令人费解了。我不知道拉康之后它变成了什么样。
So anyway, you know, he sees this bloated and indefinitely expensive back, not LaCon, process. That's full of people who thought they were God and they had this massive insecurity. and they're, you know, sort of playing God with patients' lives. They're paying, you know, being the ultimate authority on the patient's own, you know, subjective self. And some of them have these massive insecurity complexes and they're narcissists. And they sit in chairs and analyze people and tell them what's wrong with them using these metaphors that are treated a scientific fact.
总之，他看到了一个臃肿且极其昂贵的贝克（而非拉康）流程。里面充斥着自以为是上帝、实则极度缺乏安全感的人。他们把病人的生活当儿戏，自诩为病人主观自我的终极权威。其中一些人有着巨大的不安全感，是自恋者。他们坐在椅子上分析别人，用被视为科学事实的隐喻来告诉病人他们哪里出了问题。
And Beck starts to realize that they're not scientific fact. They're not really even supported by the science. you know, the Rosenhan investigation that, you talked about Rosenhand checking himself and graduate school students into a hospital, you know, he sees this crisis of confidence coming. And Beck saw the problem before Rosenhan did. His answer was clinical, not satirical. He was actually trying to fix it, whereas Rosenhand was kind of trying to actively blow it up. And when you do that, all you do is make an insecure. When you make a system that acts badly when it's insecure,
贝克开始意识到这些并非科学事实，甚至得不到科学支持。你提到的罗森汉恩将自己和研究生送进医院的调查，预示了一场信任危机。贝克比罗森汉恩更早发现了这个问题。他的回答是临床性的，而非讽刺性的。他试图解决问题，而罗森汉恩则试图彻底摧毁它。当你这样做时，你只会制造不安全感。当你建立一个在不安全时表现糟糕的系统时，
And that insecurity comes from numbers. Thank you to you to you to Porter. When you make that system more insecure, all you're going to do is make it act more badly. Or act badly more. It's kind of like in therapy, when someone's ashamed and they think the shame is going to motivate them to do better, but they're doing terribly and they're full of shame, the shame is not the answer. And shaming them more does not motivate them to change. That's why I think the resistance to this thing has to be passive.
这种不安全感源于数字。感谢波特。当你让系统变得更加不安全时，你只会让它表现得更糟。这就像在治疗中，当一个人感到羞耻，认为羞耻会激励他们做得更好，但他们表现得很糟糕且充满羞耻感时，羞耻并不是答案。羞辱他们并不能激励他们改变。这就是为什么我认为对这种东西的抵制必须是消极的。
Any active resistance is just going to be co-opted, Eden, and probably some of the people involved to punish, you know, involved in trying to make the system feel bad. You know, just the thought, you know, as the patient reports it in this moment, let's ask whether or not it's true. You know, Beck says, that's an easier thing to do than all of psychoanalysis is just say, the thing that you're thinking is it supported by evidence. And then you teach them that that thought is not always. them. That if they can say, yeah, well, it's not true or it couldn't really be that way,
任何积极的抵制都只会被收编，伊甸，可能还有一些参与惩罚的人，参与试图让系统感到难受的人。你知道，正如病人在那一刻所报告的那样，让我们问问这是否属实。贝克说，这比整个精神分析要容易得多，只需问：你所想的事情有证据支持吗？然后你教他们，那个想法并不总是代表他们自己。如果他们能说，好吧，这不是真的，或者事情不可能是那样，
then you say, okay, you're having this thought, but the thought is not having you. You don't always have to have this thought. Is there another thought we can have? And that sounds stupid, but for the time, I mean, it's pretty revolutionary. And this is, by the way, like the same move that, you know, it's a little bit more ornamented now, but like it's the same move that a parts based therapist makes, that a mindfulness-based therapist is doing. A new modality worth doing is it's dealing with multiplicity in this way where you separate the person from the thought they're having in that moment, and that separation is clinically powerful. It's the beginning of a process. Because if you, but I think if you stop there, you know, if you're just only doing,
那么你会说，好吧，你有这个想法，但这个想法并没有控制你。你不必总是拥有这个想法。我们能有别的想法吗？这听起来很蠢，但在当时，这相当具有革命性。顺便说一句，这和现在的部分疗法、正念疗法所做的动作是一样的。一种值得尝试的新模式，它以这种方式处理多样性，将人与他们那一刻的想法分离开来，这种分离在临床上非常有效。这是一个过程的开始。因为如果你停在那里，如果你只是，
pointing out where their beliefs are not supported by evidence, like some people criticize that CBT is, does too often, even though it says it does other things. Things stopping there is bad because that's a very surface level way to do therapy and the person does not have the tools at that point to continue to heal themselves outside of the room. So, which is another thing that we don't look for in research. Did this person learn something that allowed them to not ever come back to therapy, to solve the next problem, to grow, to be reconnected to a process of growth? How do you do a randomized double-blind, you know, randomized control trial for that?
指出他们的信念缺乏证据支持，就像有些人批评CBT做得太多一样，尽管它声称做了其他事情。停在那里是不好的，因为这是一种非常表层的治疗方式，而当事人此时并没有工具在咨询室外继续治愈自己。这是我们在研究中没有寻找的另一件事。这个人是否学到了让他们不必再回到治疗中，去解决下一个问题，去成长，去重新连接到成长过程中的东西？你怎么能为此做一个随机双盲对照试验呢？
but I think that's what good therapy does. And my critique of CBT, when you just stop at the process I just described, is that you haven't done that yet. So, you know, this is what Beck stumbles on. So far so good. Story of a curious clinician who lets his data change his mind, and then he builds a useful intervention out of what he learned.
但我认为这就是好的治疗所做的。我对CBT的批评是，当你只停留在刚才描述的过程时，你还没有做到这一点。所以，这就是贝克偶然发现的东西。到目前为止一切顺利。这是一个好奇的临床医生的故事，他让数据改变了自己的想法，然后根据所学构建了一个有用的干预措施。
And this is how science is supposed to work, but here's what happens next. This is where the apparatus sees what Beck did and turns him into something, he never intended to be. Never said he was. There were three properties of what Beck had built that made it perfect. Perfect for the establishment.
这就是科学应该运作的方式，但接下来发生的事情是这样的。这是机构看到贝克的做法，并把他变成了他从未打算成为的样子。他从未说过他是那样的人。贝克所构建的东西有三个特性，使它变得完美。对体制来说非常完美。
The cognitive model was manualizable. You could write the steps down and a different clinician could follow them. It was a technique more than an interpretive lens. So the cognitive model was time limited. Beck's original protocols ran on 12 to 16 sessions, which fit in. insurance coverage, you know, periods perfectly because that's how long his interventions were designed to be implemented and they were formalizable. So they were, they followed a formula. You didn't really have a lot of leeway in that formula. So you could say how long the whole
认知模型是可以手册化的。你可以写下步骤，不同的临床医生可以遵循它们。它更多是一种技术，而不是一种解释性视角。所以认知模型是有时间限制的。贝克最初的方案运行在12到16次会话之间，这与保险覆盖周期完美契合，因为他的干预措施就是这样设计的，而且它们是可形式化的。所以它们遵循一个公式。你在那个公式中没有太多的回旋余地。所以你可以说整个
process would take, which had never happened before. Psychoanalysis, you just talked until you all of a sudden stumbled on some kind of insight and then hopefully the insight changed something, but usually it didn't. And so the cognitive model was measurable on the Beck Depression inventory, which Beck himself developed in 1961. Now, you know, gave you this number. the number one up or down, you could see in real time whether or not you were doing anything that produced a change, and whether you were just talking to somebody who was entertaining you while their depression actually got worse because you're measuring it the whole time.
过程需要多长时间，这在以前从未发生过。精神分析，你只是不停地谈话，直到你突然偶然发现某种洞察力，然后希望洞察力能改变什么，但通常它不会。因此，认知模型在贝克抑郁量表上是可衡量的，这是贝克本人在1961年开发的。现在，它给了你这个数字。数字上升或下降，你可以实时看到你是否在做任何产生改变的事情，以及你是否只是在和一个让你娱乐的人交谈，而他们的抑郁症实际上变得更糟了，因为你一直在测量它。
You're not just, you know, shooting from the hip about if they're depressed or not in session. And those three properties, manualizable plus time limited plus measurable, are the properties that the emerging managed care apparatus needed. And the managed care apparatus needed a therapy that it could buy in bulk, deliver to interchangeable patients, time cap, and then audit. And Beck, completely by accident, working in good faith on a real clinical problem, had produced the only major therapy framework in American psychiatry that satisfied all three requirements at once. And the apparatus did not just select CBT because CBT was the most effective therapy. It did that later. The apparatus
你不仅仅是在会话中凭空猜测他们是否抑郁。而这三个特性，可手册化、有时限、可衡量，正是新兴的管理式医疗机构所需要的。管理式医疗机构需要一种可以批量购买、提供给可互换的病人、有时限并进行审计的疗法。而贝克，完全是偶然的，在真诚地处理一个真实的临床问题时，生产了美国精神病学中唯一同时满足这三个要求的重大治疗框架。而机构选择CBT不仅仅是因为CBT是最有效的疗法。它后来才这样做。机构
selected CBT because CBT was the therapy whose form most successfully removed the mystery from the work. and the cognitive content can be specified. Beck thought all that stuff was still there. He didn't strip it out. He thought Freud was wrong about this one thing, but he wasn't really trying to kill the depths. He just got used, you know, by the apparatus to kill the depths. And the homework assignments in CBT, they can be enumerated.
选择CBT是因为CBT的疗法形式最成功地消除了工作中的神秘感。认知内容是可以指定的。贝克认为所有那些东西仍然存在。他没有把它剥离出来。他认为弗洛伊德在这一件事上是错的，但他并不是真的想杀死深度。他只是被机构利用来杀死深度。而CBT中的家庭作业是可以列举的。
The thought record can be reviewed by a supervisor who's not in the room. The treatment can be evaluated by reading the documentation. There was finally something other than taking the therapist word for it, which, you know, people were angry, because they increasingly, more so after Beck, had done this too much with Freud. How do we let people in and find out if you're full of shit? Well, CBT gives you a lot of numbers that let you do that.
思维记录可以由不在房间里的主管审查。治疗可以通过阅读文档来评估。终于有了除了听信治疗师的话之外的东西，人们对此感到愤怒，因为在贝克之后，他们越来越多地在弗洛伊德身上做得太多了。我们如何让人们进来并找出你是否在胡说八道？好吧，CBT给了你很多数字让你这样做。
And so everything that makes CBT manualizable and measurable is also what makes CBT the kind of therapy that can be practiced without entering the mystery. A skilled therapist doing the deep work is doing something that the manual cannot describe. And they know it, and they protect that work from the manual by holding it in their own clinical mind while producing the documentation that the apparatus requires.
所以，使CBT可手册化和可衡量的所有东西，也是使CBT成为一种可以在不进入神秘领域的情况下实践的疗法的原因。一个做深层工作的熟练治疗师正在做手册无法描述的事情。他们知道这一点，并通过将工作保持在自己的临床头脑中，同时产生机构要求的文档，来保护这项工作免受手册的影响。
But the unskilled CBT therapist, the procedural worker, you know, the apparatus actually wants you more because just like the psychiatrist that we talked about, you know, Tanya Lerman. If you were trying to juggle things other than the number, you're not as effective, you're not as efficient, and you look less evidence-based. Why are you taking time to talk to this person? You know how many therapy candidates I've had that had a supervisor that said that. And they were like, well, let's talk therapy. And they're like, no, I mean about stuff other than the therapy.
但是不熟练的CBT治疗师，那个程序化工作者，机构实际上更想要你，因为就像我们谈到的精神科医生，坦尼娅·勒曼。如果你试图处理数字以外的事情，你就不那么有效，不那么高效，看起来也不那么基于证据。你为什么要花时间跟这个人说话？你知道我有多少治疗候选人有主管那样说吗？他们说，好吧，让我们谈谈治疗。他们说，不，我是指治疗以外的事情。
Why are you trying to get them to like you? And then they, as a rebellion against that, they did this study and said, oh, the evidence shows that if you get rapport with the patient, which rapport is just like a word for you like them and they like you and they enjoy being around you. It's a fancy word for that. Then the intervention will work better. The science supports that now. why did we run that research study?
你为什么要让他们喜欢你？然后，作为对这种做法的反叛，他们做了这项研究，说，哦，证据表明，如果你与病人建立融洽关系，融洽关系只是一个词，意思是他们喜欢你，你喜欢他们，他们喜欢和你在一起。这是一个花哨的词。那么干预措施会工作得更好。科学现在支持这一点。我们为什么要进行那项研究？
Why did we, for the industry to have needed to be there, you know, in the 80s, that we ran studies to see if the patient had rapport with the clinician, if therapy went better? Why is that not just a goal? What does it need to be tied to mechanism of action? And also, of course, it is. And so many things, like every angle, that's the dumbest thing in the world. But that increasingly is the world that this world became. you know, the apparatus can't tell the difference between the good CBT practitioner and the bad CBT practitioner.
为什么我们需要在80年代进行研究，看看病人是否与临床医生有融洽关系，治疗是否更好？为什么这不仅仅是一个目标？为什么它需要与作用机制挂钩？当然，它确实是。还有很多事情，就像每个角度一样，那是世界上最愚蠢的事情。但那越来越成为这个世界变成的世界。机构无法区分好的CBT从业者和坏的CBT从业者。
And so it's why a lot of people were the good psychiatrist or the bad psychiatrist. And it's why I think a lot of people defend psychiatry or CBT and say, hey, it's not as bad as everyone says. And then also why people attack it hyperbolicly is because they sort of know that there's good ones out there and bad ones out there, but they can't tell the difference. But they kind of tell that the bad ones like this more where they thrive in that water. so, you know, screw the lake. You know, the apparatus can't tell the difference between those practitioners, but it prefers one. And the apparatus does not want to tell the difference, because the difference is the variable that the apparatus has been constructed to deny.
这就是为什么很多人是好的精神科医生或坏的精神科医生。这就是为什么我认为很多人为精神病学或CBT辩护，说，嘿，它没有大家说的那么糟糕。这也是为什么人们夸张地攻击它，因为他们知道外面有好医生也有坏医生，但他们分不清。但他们能感觉到坏医生更喜欢这样，他们在那种水域中茁壮成长。所以，去他的湖泊。机构无法区分这些从业者，但它更喜欢其中一种。机构不想区分，因为这种差异是机构被构建来否认的变量。
And so telling the difference would require admitting that something matters, which can't be measured, and admitting that would dissolve the entire institutional structure. So we can't have this conversation. And now Beck himself was, you know, not part of the apparatus. By all accounts, he was, you know, late into his life, a humble guy who was clear. CBT is one tool. And he continued to read other traditions across his career. He revised, you know, his later work. He saw it as something that should change, not, you know, a solution to the problem that was American psychology. When he developed a recovery-oriented cognitive therapy
所以区分它们需要承认某些重要的事情是无法衡量的，而承认这一点会瓦解整个制度结构。所以我们不能进行这种对话。现在贝克本人并不是机构的一部分。据所有报道，他晚年是一个谦逊的人，很清楚。CBT是一种工具。他在整个职业生涯中继续阅读其他传统。他修改了他后期的工作。他将其视为应该改变的东西，而不是美国心理学问题的解决方案。当他开发恢复导向的认知疗法时
for serious mental illness in his later years, working with Paul Grant, and that was much more kind of relational and integrative, much more attuned to the developmental trauma in the context of psychosis than the standard CBT manuals would have allowed. But you can't do that. Now, I was given a manual to do CBT for schizophrenia and psychosis in the hospital that I read, and it was pretty wild. You were just kind of supposed to tell people that were having delusions that their delusions were not evidence-based that they needed to stop. That was 10 techniques to do that. We didn't get the Paul Grant model. It wasn't selected. Even though Beck made, like most of these people, some good, some bad, some in the middle things in his life, the apparatus picks what it wants.
在晚年为严重精神疾病患者服务，与保罗·格兰特合作，那更具关系性和整合性，比标准CBT手册所允许的更适应精神病背景下的发展性创伤。但你不能那样做。现在，我被给了一本手册，在医院里对精神分裂症和精神病进行CBT治疗，我读了它，这太疯狂了。你只是被要求告诉那些有妄想的人，他们的妄想缺乏证据支持，他们需要停止。有10种技术可以做到这一点。我们没有得到保罗·格兰特模型。它没有被选中。尽管贝克像大多数这些人一样，在他的一生中做了一些好的、坏的、中间的事情，但机构选择了它想要的。
You know, Beck was in many ways the version of himself that the apparatus did not want. You know, the Beck who was integrating, the Beck who was reading the semantic literature, the Beck who was acknowledging the limits of the cognitive frame, the late Beck especially, that Beck was not the Beck who got reproduced in the textbooks and in the training programs. Not even in the CBT Institute when you get certified in CBT because you're getting certified in CBT, not certified in Aaron Beck. I want to be specific about Beck's relationship to Spitzer and Francis and the DSM project as a character because this is the part that gets lost in the standard narrative.
贝克在很多方面是他自己不想要的版本。那个整合的贝克，那个阅读语义文献的贝克，那个承认认知框架局限性的贝克，尤其是晚年的贝克，那个贝克不是教科书和培训项目中复制的那个贝克。甚至在CBT研究所获得认证时也不是，因为你获得的是CBT认证，而不是亚伦·贝克认证。我想具体说明贝克与斯皮策、弗朗西斯和DSM项目作为角色的关系，因为这是标准叙事中丢失的部分。
Beck did not love what they were doing. He was not particularly enthusiastic about the DSM3. he had reservations about the categorical model. He understood that the depression and anxiety did not, in fact, carve nature at their joints the way that the manual was pretending they did. But Beck was a researcher in the DSM3 gave him a research framework, and as his work fit into that framework better than most other work, that framework was what was taken.
贝克并不喜欢他们正在做的事情。他对DSM-3并不特别热心。他对分类模型有保留意见。他明白抑郁和焦虑实际上并没有像手册假装的那样在关节处切割自然。但贝克是一名研究人员，DSM-3给了他一个研究框架，由于他的工作比大多数其他工作更适合那个框架，那个框架就是被采纳的东西。
Whether or not he endorsed everything that the framework was doing, it's what was taken from him. and it's all of him that survived. And the apparatus didn't need his endorsement to do it. It didn't need his tools. Like Francis, like Spencer, you can protest these symptoms. You can say you were using me wrong.
无论他是否认可框架正在做的一切，这就是从他那里拿走的东西。这就是他幸存下来的全部。机构不需要他的认可来做这件事。它不需要他的工具。像弗朗西斯，像斯皮策，你可以抗议这些症状。你可以说你用错了。
You can say, I made a mistake. Like John Nash, you know, we talked about the mathematician who was used to sort of create the Cold War. You can say, I was crazy and I was wrong. and it does not matter. We've taken what we need from you. We have taken you at your most insecure because it flatters us
你可以说，我犯了一个错误。像约翰·纳什，我们谈到的那个被用来创造冷战的数学家。你可以说，我疯了，我错了。这无关紧要。我们已经从你那里拿走了我们需要的东西。我们已经把你最不安全的一面拿走了，因为它恭维了我们
and are most insecure so well that we don't have to see our own insecurity. The apparatus didn't steal from Beck and it didn't corrupt it. It didn't force Beck to do anything he didn't want to do. What it did is something subtler and more powerful. It took the parts of Beck's work that it needed.
以及我们最不安全的一面，以至于我们不必看到自己的不安全感。机构没有从贝克那里偷窃，也没有腐蚀它。它没有强迫贝克做任何他不想做的事情。它所做的是更微妙、更强大的事情。它拿走了贝克工作中它需要的部分。
It scaled those parts. It let the rest atrophy. The manualizable parts get manualized. the measurable parts get measured, the time-limited parts get time-capped, and the parts that Beck did not, you know, want to be taken out, the curiosity, the integration, the willingness to revise, the late career humility, the recovery-oriented work with serious mental illness,
它扩展了这些部分。它让其余部分萎缩。可手册化的部分被手册化了，可衡量的部分被测量了，有时限的部分被设定了时间上限，而贝克不想被拿走的部分，好奇心、整合、修改的意愿、晚年的谦逊、针对严重精神疾病的恢复导向工作，
the acknowledgement of the environment, the implicit acknowledgement that the cognitive frame was just a starting point and not the destination. And it should never be mistaken for that. All of that gets quietly left out of the version of CBT that gets reproduced at scale. And the Beck that you encountered in a master's level training program in 2026 is not Beck. It's the parts of Beck that the apparatus selected for.
对环境的承认，对认知框架只是起点而非终点的隐含承认。它永远不应该被误认为是那样。所有这些都被悄悄地排除在CBT版本之外，并在规模上进行复制。而你在2026年的硕士培训项目中遇到的贝克不是贝克。它是机构为之选择的贝克的部分。
And it's the Beck as protocol. Beck with the curiosity removed, Beck as something an 18-month online degree can teach, a graduate to do with fidelity. And the people who reproduce this version of Beck do not even know that it's not Beck. They've not only encountered a captured version. and they believe that they are doing what Beck did, when they are doing the worst things, and sometimes the things you disagreed with. They're doing what the apparatus expected from what Beck did.
它是作为协议的贝克。去除了好奇心的贝克，作为18个月在线学位可以教导毕业生忠实执行的东西。而复制这个版本贝克的人甚至不知道那不是贝克。他们不仅遇到了一个被捕获的版本，而且他们相信他们正在做贝克所做的事情，而他们正在做最糟糕的事情，有时是你不同意的事情。他们正在做机构从贝克所做的事情中期望的东西。
You know, when you take objectivity, when you take quantification to this extreme, you end up back in a very religious place. How many of the founders of the world religions would like the religion as it currently exist, and its majority if they showed back up. Now, this is what capture looks like. It doesn't require villains.
当你把客观性、量化推向这种极端时，你最终会回到一个非常宗教的地方。如果世界宗教的创始人现在出现，他们中有多少人会喜欢目前存在的宗教及其多数派。现在，这就是捕获的样子。它不需要恶棍。
It requires no conspiracy. It does not require the founder's consent or refusal. It requires only the founder's work contain properties that the apparatus needs and that the apparatus have enough institutional power to scale the useful properties while letting the rest fade. You know, Beck was a careful, curious clinician who let his data change his mind.
它不需要阴谋。它不需要创始人的同意或拒绝。它只需要创始人的工作包含机构需要的属性，并且机构有足够的制度力量来扩展有用的属性，同时让其余部分消退。贝克是一个细心、好奇的临床医生，他让数据改变了自己的想法。
The version of Beck that lives in the apparatus is a checklist. And the distance between those two things is the distance that I'm asking you to see because the same distance shows up in every modality the apparatus is captured. And the same mechanism produces it every time. Campbell's law says that any quantitative indicator used to make decisions distorts the process that it is meant to monitor. And Goodhart's law is the same observation sort of. You know, when a measure becomes a target, it ceases to be a good measurement.
生活在机构中的贝克版本是一个清单。这两者之间的距离就是我要求你看到的距离，因为同样的距离出现在机构捕获的每一种模式中。同样的机制每次都会产生它。坎贝尔定律说，任何用于决策的定量指标都会扭曲它旨在监测的过程。古德哈特定律也是同样的观察。当一个衡量标准成为目标时，它就不再是一个好的衡量标准。
because everything that isn't the measurement is now able to be sacrificed. Anything that isn't that number or can't be captured in a number is now ruined. And no target, no real target in the real world exists in that way. Corey Doctro writes about inshittification and technology. He writes about the Rod economy. You know, Ed Zetron has a podcast on that. That's pretty good if you were interested in the, economics of LLMs. But, you know, the patterns that they're looking at in Silicon Valley are
因为所有不是衡量标准的东西现在都可以被牺牲。任何不是那个数字或不能被数字捕获的东西现在都被毁了。现实世界中没有真正的目标是以那种方式存在的。科里·多克托罗写了关于技术中的“垃圾化”。他写了关于棒经济的文章。埃德·泽特伦有一个关于这个的播客。如果你对LLM的经济学感兴趣，那还不错。但是，他们在硅谷观察到的模式是
describing what platforms do when they have eliminated their competition and they capture regulators and they've locked users in and then they make the product systematically worse on purpose to extract more value from people who have nowhere else to go. And Silicon Valley may hit a monopoly before the other institutions in America do. Or they may hit the, that point of total institutional capture and then freedom that results in monopoly conditions. That doesn't mean that we should let them do that or other things do it, but it may be a good case study in just how power and bureaucracy work. You know, the pattern goes like this.
描述平台在消除竞争、捕获监管机构并锁定用户后所做的事情，然后他们故意使产品系统性地变差，以从无处可去的人那里提取更多价值。硅谷可能在其他美国机构之前达到垄断。或者他们可能达到那种完全的制度捕获，然后导致垄断条件的自由。这并不意味着我们应该让他们这样做或其他事情这样做，但这可能是一个关于权力和官僚机构如何运作的好案例研究。模式是这样的。
First, the platform is good to users to attract them. And then once the users are locked in, the platform is good to the business customers at the expense of the users. And then once the business customers are also locked in, then the platform extracts value from both making the experience worth for everyone except for the platform's shareholders. And the reason that this is possible is that the platform has eliminated all the forces that would normally discipline a bad actor. And market competition is gone because the platform has, you know,
首先，平台对用户很好以吸引他们。一旦用户被锁定，平台就会以牺牲用户为代价对商业客户很好。一旦商业客户也被锁定，平台就会从两者中提取价值，使体验对除平台股东以外的每个人来说都变得更糟。之所以可能，是因为平台消除了所有通常会惩罚不良行为者的力量。市场竞争消失了，因为平台已经
bought or destroyed its competitors. And then the regulatory oversight is gone because the platform is large enough to capture the regulators or the regulators become part of the company. And then vice versa. And worker leverage is gone because the platform. platform has fragmented its workforce into gig laborers who can't collectively bargain. Any of this sound familiar. Consumer alternatives are gone because the platform has structured the network so that
购买或摧毁了竞争对手。监管监督消失了，因为平台足够大，可以捕获监管机构，或者监管机构成为公司的一部分。反之亦然。工人的杠杆作用消失了，因为平台将劳动力碎片化为无法集体谈判的零工劳动者。这听起来耳熟吗？消费者替代方案消失了，因为平台构建了网络，使得
leaving costs more than staying. And then once all four constraints are eliminated, the platform is free to be as bad as it wants. And it will be as bad as it wants because the people who run the platforms are not bad people in some special sense. They are responding to an environmental reward. to being terrible to you as a customer in order to make more money for a company. And American mental health care has gone through scary parallels to that.
离开的成本高于留下的成本。一旦所有四个约束都被消除，平台就可以随心所欲地变坏。它会随心所欲地变坏，因为运营平台的人并不是某种特殊意义上的坏人。他们是在响应环境奖励，对你作为客户表现得很糟糕，以便为公司赚更多的钱。而美国心理健康护理经历了可怕的平行情况。
We're not as far along as Google, but it's a similar system. American health care, American education as a privatized increasingly service. You know, the four constraints that should have prevented this have been eliminated in the same ways. competition is gone. Thousands of insurance carriers became a small number of national carriers. They don't compete with each other in meaningful ways on the quality of mental health coverage. They have arrived by parallel calculation at the same protocols. 12 sessions, CBT preferred, medical necessity reviews at session 10, prior authorization for anything beyond manualized brief therapy.
我们还没有像谷歌那样走得那么远，但这是一个类似的系统。美国医疗保健、美国教育作为一种私有化的服务。四个本应防止这种情况发生的约束已经在同样的方式下被消除了。竞争消失了。数千家保险公司变成了少数几家全国性保险公司。它们在心理健康覆盖质量上没有以有意义的方式竞争。它们通过平行计算得出了相同的协议。12次会话，首选CBT，第10次会话进行医疗必要性审查，对任何超出手册化简短治疗的内容进行预先授权。
You know, the pharmacy benefit managers do the same dance with medication. The credentialing pathways are controlled by a small number of accrediting bodies that have arrived at the same curriculum. CPT codes are negotiated by the AMA's relative value scale update committee. There's a million things that I could do. And last time I mentioned the RUC, a psychiatrist emailed me and told me that our country's medical policy was a conspiracy theory that I made up. And he should know because he was a professor emeritus and he would have heard about something like that, which should be scary. should be scary to anyone listening. That is the state of the field.
药房福利经理对药物也做同样的舞蹈。认证途径由少数几个认证机构控制，它们得出了相同的课程。CPT代码由AMA的相对价值量表更新委员会协商。我可以做一百万件事。上次我提到RUC时，一位精神科医生给我发电子邮件，告诉我我们国家的医疗政策是我编造的阴谋论。他应该知道，因为他是名誉教授，他应该听说过这样的事情，这应该很可怕。对任何听众来说都应该很可怕。这就是该领域的现状。
But there's no competing system. There's no alternative market. You know, if you want to use your insurance to get mental health care in America in 2026, the system you encounter is structurally identical regardless of which insurance card you carry. I guess you could not have insurance. But, I mean, that's just to be rich, you know, get out of jail free card, right? You know, regulatory capture is gone. And I mean the regulators who should be policing the apparatus have been so thoroughly captured by it
但没有竞争系统。没有替代市场。如果你想在2026年使用你的保险在美国获得心理健康护理，你遇到的系统在结构上是相同的，无论你持有哪张保险卡。我想你可以没有保险。但那只是为了富有，你知道，免费出狱卡，对吧？监管捕获消失了。我的意思是，本应监管机构的监管者已经被它彻底捕获了
that the regulation has become a form of cooperation. And the agencies that should be enforcing mental health parity have been so defanged that the Mental Health Parity and Addiction Equity Act of 2008 functions in practice as a suggestion. And the licensing boards that should be policing clinician quality have been captured by the professional self-interest and now function primarily as gatekeepers protecting current practitioners from competing rather than ensuring patient quality. You know, the Joint Commission's behavioral health standards have been written in consultation with the institutions the standards are supposed to regulate.
以至于监管已经成为一种合作形式。本应执行心理健康平等的机构已经被去势，以至于2008年的《心理健康平等与成瘾公平法案》在实践中起到了建议的作用。本应监管临床医生质量的许可委员会已经被专业自身利益所捕获，现在主要作为保护现有从业者免受竞争的守门人，而不是确保病人质量。联合委员会的行为健康标准是在与标准本应监管的机构协商后编写的。
And the accreditation bodies for graduate training programs operate on a fee-for-service model in which the accredited programs pay the accreditor, which produces exactly the conflict of interest that you would expect. And the FDA, which sets the framework for what can be prescribed and how operates inside an industry, funded user fee structure that has not been seriously reformed in three decades. But if you follow those rules and you pay that ethics commission, you are ethical and you are evidence-based. Worker leverage is gone. Clinicians are no longer in a position to collectively refuse the conditions of the work. The credentialing pathways have been atomized
研究生培训项目的认证机构以按服务收费的模式运作，其中认证项目支付认证机构，这产生了你所预期的利益冲突。而设定处方框架和方式的FDA在行业内部运作，资助用户费结构，三十年来没有进行过认真的改革。但如果你遵循这些规则并支付那个道德委员会，你就是道德的，你就是基于证据的。工人杠杆作用消失了。临床医生不再处于能够集体拒绝工作条件的地位。认证途径已经被原子化
across multiple licenses, none of which gives clinicians enough collective power to negotiate. Insurance reimbursement rates are set unilaterally and clinician. have no leverage to negotiate. The administrative burden has expanded to the point that solo practice is barely viable financially, forcing clinicians into group practices and health systems that further reduce their autonomy. The few unionization attempts in mental health, primarily at large hospital systems and digital platforms have been met with the standard playbook of corporate union busting, and also it's illegal for private practice therapists to form any sort of union. That would be considered a cartel.
跨越多个执照，没有一个能给临床医生足够的集体力量来谈判。保险报销率是单方面设定的，临床医生没有谈判的杠杆。行政负担已经扩大到个人执业在经济上几乎不可行的程度，迫使临床医生进入进一步减少其自主权的团体执业和卫生系统。心理健康领域的少数工会化尝试，主要是在大型医院系统和数字平台，遭到了企业工会破坏的标准剧本，而且私人执业治疗师组建任何形式的工会也是非法的。那会被视为卡特尔。
You know, when the AMA does it with the RUC, they get a pass. Anyone else does that? It's a cartel under the law. And the result is that clinicians cannot collectively refuse the apparatus's condition. And individual clinicians who refuse end up financially priced out of the field. And patient alternatives are gone structurally. You know, the ghost network problem, you know, the insurance companies pretend to have these robust networks just by not really checking who in them is still alive or taking a piece. patients. You know, the end network provider directories are full of clinicians who are not actually
当AMA用RUC这样做时，他们得到了通行证。其他人这样做？根据法律，这是一个卡特尔。结果是临床医生无法集体拒绝机构的条件。而拒绝的个人临床医生最终在经济上被挤出了该领域。病人的替代方案在结构上消失了。你知道，幽灵网络问题，保险公司假装拥有这些强大的网络，只是通过不真正检查其中谁还活着或接受病人。网络内提供者目录中充满了实际上并不
accepting patients. And, you know, the patient who tries to find care and network discovers that the director is actually a fiction and that no one does any of the things that, you know, evidence-based medicine says would treat the thing that they have. They're kind of full of these certain types of clinicians. And the patient who looks for alternatives outside the medical system finds this unregulated wilderness of life coaches and app-based wellness products and scams and abuse, a lot of times. And the apparatus has structured the field so that there is no real exit for the patient. So you have the same four conditions that produce in stratification on a digital platform,
接受病人的临床医生。试图在网络内寻找护理的病人发现目录实际上是虚构的，没有人做基于证据的医学所说的治疗他们所患疾病的事情。它们充满了这些特定类型的临床医生。而在医疗系统之外寻找替代方案的病人发现了这个不受监管的荒野，充满了生活教练、基于应用程序的健康产品、骗局和虐待。机构已经构建了该领域，使得病人没有真正的出口。所以你有产生数字平台垃圾化的四个条件，
and all four of them are present in the mental health care and largely the health care sector in this country. And the result is the same. The product gets systematically worse. The clinicians spend more time on documentation and less time with the patient. And if you look at how this thing worked, we didn't focus on this super closely, but in the 80s when this was sold as freedom and they went after the patients. Then the patients got pissed in the 90s, so they went after the businesses.
而这四个条件在这个国家的心理健康护理和很大程度上的医疗保健部门中都存在。结果是一样的。产品系统性地变差。临床医生花更多时间在文档上，花更少时间与病人在一起。如果你看看这个东西是如何运作的，我们没有非常密切地关注这一点，但在80年代，当这被作为自由出售时，他们追逐病人。然后病人在90年代生气了，所以他们追逐企业。
And then after they went after the businesses and they had them, they said, you can't leave. It's too expensive and there's nowhere to go. And then the businesses and the patients were stuck. And the machine kept going. It didn't matter. Even though everybody was in agreement, largely that it was bad. What do you do? And the cruelest piece, which, you know, doctor, own names, you know,
在他们追逐企业并抓住他们之后，他们说，你不能离开。这太贵了，没有地方可去。然后企业和病人被困住了。机器继续运转。这无关紧要。尽管每个人都同意，很大程度上它是坏的。你做什么？最残酷的部分，你知道，医生，自己的名字，你知道，
when he's talking about insidification in his writing is that clinicians who absorb, I mean, he's talking about tech, not clinicians, but he says this thing, you know, clinicians who absorb the financial and moral costs of insidification, the people who are the ones who are in the crumple zone, they're not the people who designed it. They're in a system that extracts the value of their labor while making them carry the blame for failure. We talked about some of the meeting-making apparatuses in America.
当他在写作中谈论垃圾化时，临床医生吸收了垃圾化的经济和道德成本，那些处于崩溃区的人，他们不是设计它的人。他们处于一个提取他们劳动价值的系统中，同时让他们承担失败的责任。我们谈到了美国的一些意义制造机构。
and when they died in the Industrial Revolution in the 40s and the 50s and the 60s. And the reverence is now, you know, supposed to be given to this one institution because it's positioned itself as the legitimate inheritor of all the cultural roles that used to be filled by all this other stuff, which, you know, granted, had some problems and wasn't scientific. But it wasn't supposed to be. It was priests and elders and unions and traditional healers and, you know, the nature of a family structure that the profit motive and the material conditions made more room for than they do now.
当它们在工业革命中，在40年代、50年代和60年代死亡时。现在，人们应该对这个机构表示敬意，因为它将自己定位为所有文化角色的合法继承者，这些角色曾经由所有其他东西填充，这，诚然，有一些问题，不是科学的。但它本不应该是科学的。它是牧师、长老、工会、传统治疗师，以及家庭结构的本质，利润动机和物质条件比现在留下了更多的空间。
You know, the easiest people to make liable are probably the schools for the clinicians they produce, which right now they're pretty protected by being diploma mills in a lot of cases, or just not being terribly concerned with the outcomes of who they graduate. You also could remove the sovereign immunity from some licensing boards. See if the types of people that are on the boards now still want to be on them if they had a little bit of skin in the game. Because my guess is that they wouldn't. You would get people who maybe had a vision for getting rid of people, which would cause some money to not go to places that it's supposed to go, which is why we don't do that. It's why we don't have accountability in that way.
最容易承担责任的人可能是他们培养临床医生的学校，目前它们在很多情况下受到作为文凭工厂的保护，或者只是不太关心他们毕业的人的结果。你也可以从一些许可委员会中取消主权豁免。看看现在在委员会上的人是否在他们有一点利害关系时还想在上面。因为我的猜测是他们不会。你会得到可能有愿景去摆脱人们的人，这会导致一些钱不去它应该去的地方，这就是为什么我们不那样做。这就是为什么我们没有那种方式的问责制。
You have to be willing to say things like there is no ethical way to work inside of this system. ethical way to work for this kind of business. And a lot of the businesses that send me emails as a social worker wanting to be a gig worker, there are things in the
你必须愿意说出这样的话：在这个系统内工作没有道德方式。为这种企业工作没有道德方式。而许多作为社会工作者想要成为零工劳动者给我发电子邮件的企业，在这些事情中存在着
If they do, their license can be taken. And now this company cannot hire social workers. And if you do that, I think, well, I think there's a reason why we don't do that. And you have to prepare for the thing that will survive the AI displacement to be the thing that was never fungible in the first place. The clinician who could sit with another nervous system and read the dimensional profile in real time and weight the layers and notice the autonomic shift in the room and integrate the trauma context with the attachment history and the cultural framing and with the symbolic content of the dream, patient brought in. And I don't think that AI can do this technically, even if it can do it intellectually some of the time. Because the AI is not able to read the nervous system of the patient in the way that skilled clinicians, whether or not they knew they're doing somatic work, see posture, see tone
如果他们这样做，他们的执照可能会被吊销。现在这家公司不能再雇佣社会工作者了。如果你这样做，我想，嗯，我想我们不这样做是有原因的。你必须为那些能在人工智能取代中幸存下来的事物做好准备，这些事物从一开始就是不可替代的。临床医生可以与另一个神经系统坐在一起，实时读取维度特征，权衡各个层面，注意到房间里的自主神经变化，并将创伤背景与依恋历史、文化框架以及患者带来的梦境的象征性内容整合在一起。我不认为人工智能在技术上能做到这一点，即使它有时在智力上能做到。因为人工智能无法像熟练的临床医生那样读取患者的神经系统，无论他们是否知道自己在进行躯体工作，他们能看到姿势，看到语调
and see differences in those things. It's not all prefrontal cortex language and talk therapy. Freud said that the problem of civilization could never go away, that human beings cannot tolerate what they actually are, and they build these institutions to defend themselves from what they actually are because they don't want to see it, and the institutions become the new thing that they can't tolerate, and so they tear them down, but that we are incompatible with reality in a certain way.
并看到这些事物中的差异。这不仅仅是前额叶皮层的语言和谈话疗法。弗洛伊德说，文明的问题永远无法消除，人类无法忍受他们真实的自我，他们建立这些机构来保护自己免受真实自我的影响，因为他们不想看到它，而这些机构变成了他们无法忍受的新事物，所以他们拆毁了它们，但在某种程度上，我们与现实是不相容的。
And I disagree with some of his reasons, but I think in broad strokes, there is an evin flow to that that is right. You know, we build new defenses against, institutions and the cycle never ends and the insecurity at the root of the institution is the same insecurity that the institutions were built to defend against. And the apparatus is bad because the people who built it could not tolerate what they were trying to study. And the reform of the apparatus will produce a new apparatus that the next generation will also not be able to tolerate.
我不同意他的一些理由，但我认为大体上，这种起伏是正确的。你知道，我们建立新的防御机制来对抗机构，而这个循环永无止境，机构根源上的不安全感与机构旨在防御的不安全感是相同的。这个机构是糟糕的，因为建造它的人无法忍受他们试图研究的东西。而对机构的改革将产生一个新的机构，下一代也将无法忍受。
But you can do that in a better direction than we're doing it now. You know, bureaucracy is the most successful avoidance technology that humans have ever invented. You can spend a 40-year career filling out forms that are defending you from the thing that you became a therapist to encounter. And at the end, you can retire with a pension, having never once entered the room that you were ostensibly working in. And the forms are the defense. The forms feel like work. The forms protect us from the patients. And the diagnosis protects us from the suffering. And the protocols protect us from the not knowing. And the accreditation protects us from the question of whether we are any good. But that's the reason that you went into the profession,
但你可以朝着比我们现在更好的方向去做。你知道，官僚主义是人类发明过的最成功的逃避技术。你可以花40年的职业生涯填写表格，这些表格保护你免受你成为治疗师所要面对的事物的影响。最后，你可以带着养老金退休，却从未真正进入你表面上工作的那个房间。表格就是防御。表格感觉就像工作。表格保护我们免受患者的影响。诊断保护我们免受痛苦的影响。协议保护我们免受未知的影响。认证保护我们免受关于我们是否优秀的质疑。但这就是你进入这个行业的原因，
was to figure out if you were any good, whether or not you know it. Are you more scared of a part of you that if you accepted it would let you see life clearly, then you are of not seeing life clearly? And most people answer yes. Most people would rather not see life clearly that encounter the part of themselves that they have been refusing. And that is the engine of the apparatus. The patient who refuses to grow becomes the field that refuses to grow because the institution that defends the refusal at scale.
是为了弄清楚你是否优秀，无论你是否知道。你是否更害怕你内心的一部分，如果你接受了它，它会让你看清生活，而不是害怕看不清生活？大多数人回答是。大多数人宁愿看不清生活，也不愿面对他们一直拒绝的内心部分。这就是机构的引擎。拒绝成长的患者变成了拒绝成长的领域，因为机构在规模上捍卫了这种拒绝。
The micro and the macro are not analogies. They are the same thing seen at different resolutions. And the work is in the willingness to accept the part of yourself that if you accepted it would force you to see what you have been refusing to see. Therapist does this in themselves so that they can be present with the patient doing it in themselves. And the AI can never do this
微观和宏观不是类比。它们是在不同分辨率下看到的同一事物。工作在于愿意接受你内心的一部分，如果你接受了它，它会强迫你看到你一直拒绝看到的东西。治疗师在自己身上这样做，以便能够与同样在自己身上做这件事的患者同在。而人工智能永远无法做到这一点，
because the AI has nothing to refuse. There's no part of the AI. that the AI has been refusing to see. The AI can simulate the language of the work, but it cannot do the work because the work is the encounter with the part of yourself you've been hiding from. And the chewing on that that comes out in a conversation with another person, and the AI does not have a self to hide from. And maybe this is permanent.
因为人工智能没有什么可拒绝的。人工智能没有哪一部分是它一直拒绝看到的。人工智能可以模拟工作的语言，但它无法完成工作，因为工作是与你一直躲避的内心部分相遇。在与另一个人的对话中咀嚼这些内容，而人工智能没有可以躲避的自我。也许这是永久性的。
Maybe Freud was right, and maybe humans will always refuse what they are. Maybe we are always going to be the species that can't quite bear to know what we are. And maybe that is psychological. But here's the line. If humans will always refuse, professional psychology should probably stop being the most refined refusal in the culture. And the institution dedicated to the problem should stop being part of the problem. That is a smaller wager than fixing human nature, but it is the wager that is actually available to us. In the end of the professionalized version of human avoidance that has been claimed to be a
也许弗洛伊德是对的，也许人类永远会拒绝他们真实的自我。也许我们永远会是那个无法忍受了解自己真实模样的物种。也许这是心理上的。但重点是：如果人类总是会拒绝，专业心理学或许应该停止成为文化中最精致的拒绝。致力于解决问题的机构应该停止成为问题的一部分。这比修复人性是一个更小的赌注，但这是我们实际上可以做出的赌注。在人类逃避的专业化版本的尽头，这种逃避被声称为
It's opposite for 100 years. The cold machines are nothing. The worm ghost is everything. The worm ghost is what we keep finding, century after century. No matter how many walls get built between us and it. And the worm ghost is the encounter between two animals who are willing to look at each other and be changed by what they see. And the worm ghost is what civilization has been trying to manage and contain
100年来它的对立面。冰冷的机器什么都不是。蠕虫幽灵就是一切。蠕虫幽灵是我们世纪复一世纪不断发现的东西。无论我们与它之间筑起了多少墙。蠕虫幽灵是两个愿意看着对方并被所见之物所改变的动物之间的相遇。蠕虫幽灵是文明一直试图管理和控制的东西，
and procedure and bill for. and the worm ghost keeps escaping because the worm ghost is constitutive of what it is to be a creature in a relationship with another creature and no amount of apparatus can finally contain that.
并将其程序化和计费。而蠕虫幽灵不断逃脱，因为蠕虫幽灵构成了作为一种与另一种生物建立关系的生物的本质，任何数量的机构最终都无法包含这一点。
Hold the ghost. This is what the whole series is in three words. Hold the ghost. The machines will try to dream but they can't. Only you can dream and only you can keep backing up and zooming in in the way that humans do that is useful. You know, before
抓住幽灵。这就是整个系列用三个词概括的内容。抓住幽灵。机器会试图做梦，但它们做不到。只有你能做梦，只有你能像人类那样不断后退和放大，这是有用的。你知道，在
psychology, you know, before universities carved knowledge into departments, there was a single discipline. It was just called natural philosophy. It was the inquiry into how the world worked. You know, not physics, not medicine, not ethics, all of these things it was. It was understood as a continuous field of attention. Newton didn't call himself a physicist. the word didn't exist until 1830. He wrote about gravity, light, motion, under the same cover because to him they were the same inquiry,
心理学之前，在大学将知识划分为各个系之前，有一门单一的学科。它被称为自然哲学。它是对世界如何运作的探究。不是物理学，不是医学，不是伦理学，所有这些都是它。它被理解为一个连续的关注领域。牛顿不称自己为物理学家，这个词直到1830年才出现。他把关于重力、光、运动的著作写在同一本书里，因为对他来说，它们是同一种探究，
and Darwin sailed not as a biologist, but as a naturalist, studying geology, beetles, finches, coral reefs, you know, with the same pair of eyes from the same posture of radical curiosity. The formal disciplines came later. The walls came later, but the knowledge came first,
达尔文航行时不是作为生物学家，而是作为博物学家，研究地质学、甲虫、雀类、珊瑚礁，你知道，用同一双眼睛，从同样的激进好奇心的姿态出发。正式的学科是后来才有的。墙是后来才有的，但知识是先有的，
and the knowledge is still there. Psychotherapy has lived inside a teeny-tiny-tiny-walled garden for a century now. And it didn't make the world go away, and it didn't make humanity any smaller. Just because you looked at them under a microscope. It has departments, you know, cognitive, behavioral, psychodynamic, semantic, existential, existential. It has turf wars, credentialing bodies, approved modalities, and evidence hierarchies. And these structures have produced real things. And randomized controlled trials do tell us something. And manualized protocols save lives. So no serious practitioner can pretend otherwise. But something has been
而知识依然存在。心理治疗已经在一个小小的围墙花园里生活了一个世纪。它并没有让世界消失，也没有让人类变得更渺小。仅仅因为你在显微镜下观察他们。它有各个部门，你知道，认知、行为、心理动力学、语义学、存在主义。它有地盘之争、认证机构、批准的模式和证据等级。这些结构确实产生了一些真实的东西。随机对照试验确实告诉了我们一些事情。手册化的协议挽救了生命。所以没有严肃的从业者可以假装不是这样。但有些东西已经
lost that is very hard to name precisely because the loss happened at the level of orientation rather than content. We've accumulated expertise, but what we have misplaced is the sense that everything is connected. And like the future of the field doesn't need a polymath therapist who's read more books. Arguably, it needs less of them. You know, accumulated expertise in service of the same fundamental framework doesn't change the framework. What psychology needs is a shift in orientation towards what we might call an architecture of coherence. An architecture of coherence doesn't dismantle specialization or empirical knowledge. It knows when to call itself a neuroscientist, a spiritual director, a body worker, a pharmacologist, or simply an open being, a pilgrim. And,
丢失了，很难准确命名，因为这种丢失发生在方向层面而不是内容层面。我们积累了专业知识，但我们错失的是万物相连的感觉。就像这个领域的未来不需要一个读过更多书的博学治疗师。可以说，它需要更少这样的书。你知道，为同一个基本框架服务的积累的专业知识并不能改变框架。心理学需要的是向我们可能称之为连贯性架构的方向转变。连贯性架构并不拆除专业化或经验知识。它知道何时称自己为神经科学家、精神导师、身体工作者、药理学家，或者仅仅是一个开放的存在，一个朝圣者。而且，
you know, from the assumption that the person in the room is not just this bundle of discrete problems to be sorted into specialist channels, but a person as a whole embedded in a body and a system in a cultural moment, a symbolic universe, in a cosmos that may not be indifferent to suffering, because we can make it not indifferent for a moment. And that might be the mechanism of action. It may be the primary one or the only one that we need in a way that we can't ever study. And the walls around this stuff came later. The knowledge, the living undivided knowledge, of what it all means to be a person in this world came first, but it'll never be known and it'll never be solved. But it does remain available to anyone who's willing to restore their orientation
你知道，基于这样一个假设：房间里的人不仅仅是一堆需要分类到专家渠道的离散问题，而是一个完整的人，嵌入在身体、系统、文化时刻、象征宇宙中，在一个可能并不对痛苦漠不关心的宇宙中，因为我们可以让它暂时不漠不关心。这可能是作用机制。它可能是主要的机制，或者我们唯一需要的机制，以一种我们永远无法研究的方式。围绕这些东西的墙是后来才有的。知识，关于在这个世界上作为一个人的全部意义的鲜活的、未分割的知识，是先有的，但它永远不会被完全知晓，也永远不会被解决。但它确实对任何愿意恢复其方向的人保持开放。
to it. Machines can hide that or they can pretend it's unimportant and they can pretend that they can create those things, but they can ever see them. You know, the field will serve all of us better if we meet each other in a curious, undefended space. And if we're willing to reach not across party lines, but across walls, and across the edges of knowledge, places that feel scary and places that we feel like we can't go are probably the places that we should go. and I think that should be the barometer, I mean the compass. Go the places that feel like they're not allowed.
机器可以隐藏这一点，或者它们可以假装它不重要，它们可以假装它们能创造这些东西，但它们永远无法看到它们。你知道，如果我们在一个好奇、不设防的空间里相遇，这个领域将更好地为我们所有人服务。如果我们愿意跨越的不是党派界限，而是墙壁，跨越知识的边缘，那些感觉可怕的地方和我们觉得不能去的地方，可能正是我们应该去的地方。我认为这应该是晴雨表，我是说指南针。去那些感觉好像不被允许去的地方。
And ask yourself if there's a place that I would be better off exploring and the world would be better off for me exploring, but it feels like I'm not allowed to do that. Ask yourself why? Because the field definitely has it and the field needs to. And the field is made up of a lot of people who can do that. And in the very center of the eye, there's this thing called scotoma. And it's where the optic nerve enters in the back of the eye, and you can't actually see anything there.
问问自己，是否有一个地方我探索会更好，世界也会因为我的探索而变得更好，但感觉好像我不被允许这样做。问问自己为什么？因为这个领域肯定有它，而且这个领域需要它。这个领域由许多能做到这一点的人组成。在眼睛的正中心，有一个东西叫盲点。它是视神经进入眼球后部的地方，你实际上在那里什么也看不见。
Like in the middle of your vision right now, there's a blind spot. But you don't know that because what your brain does is it takes all this information from around the edges of that blind spot. And it fills it in. So what you see in the middle of your visual field is actually a guess that your brain makes. That's a pretty wild and pretty good guess and that you never see it. Of all of the little things around that and what you saw right before you moved your eye and moved your blind spot over a little bit, what it guesses is still there. And it can compensate for things like light, motion, flickery rates, all kinds of crazy things that it does without your permission all the time.
就像你现在的视野中间，有一个盲点。但你不知道，因为你的大脑所做的是从盲点边缘获取所有这些信息。然后它填补了它。所以你在视野中间看到的东西实际上是你大脑做出的猜测。那是一个相当狂野且相当好的猜测，你永远看不到它。关于周围的所有小事物，以及你在移动眼睛并稍微移动盲点之前看到的东西，它猜测它仍然在那里。它可以补偿光线、运动、闪烁率等各种疯狂的事情，它在没有你许可的情况下一直在做这些事情。
But you can't see your own. And that's not your fault. You can only see that blind spot in the eye. You know, psychology here being America's eye in which it encounters itself. through other people, when you have lots of eyes looking together, but not from the same perspective and not from the same mechanistic orientation, you know, from a field of subjective experience. Because you can't make yourself see it. You can't count it. You can't actually know where it begins. And, you know, the bullshit that your brain is making up about what is in this
但你看不见你自己的盲点。这不是你的错。你只能看到眼睛里的那个盲点。你知道，心理学在这里是美国的眼睛，它通过其他人来认识自己。当你有很多眼睛一起看，但不是从同一个视角，也不是从同一个机械化的方向，你知道，从一个主观体验的领域。因为你无法让自己看到它。你无法计算它。你无法真正知道它从哪里开始。而且，你知道，你的大脑关于这个
spot where your optic nerve is entering the back of your eye is. You can't. No, there's no way to. You can only, through the perception of many people that are curious and open and looking for the blind spot, can you begin to sort of guess where it is. But it's not a destination, it's not a number, and it's not a hard rule, and it never will be. And if we want to hold that blind spot as a culture, I think we have to start looking in a very different way than we have been for the last little while. Cold promise ain't so In aesthetic there's a soul
视神经进入眼球后部的地方编造的胡说八道是什么。你不能。不，没有办法。你只能通过许多好奇、开放并寻找盲点的人的感知，才能开始猜测它在哪里。但它不是目的地，不是数字，也不是硬性规则，永远不会是。如果我们想作为一个文化来保持那个盲点，我认为我们必须开始以一种与过去一段时间完全不同的方式来看待它。冰冷的承诺并非如此，在美学中有一个灵魂
Broken rope into tune You fall asleep on my shoulder Fan spin Metal flumes I close the lid to dark You'll see you're teaching this old wire There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
断裂的绳子调入音律，你在我的肩膀上睡着，风扇旋转，金属烟道，我关上盖子陷入黑暗，你会看到你正在教这根旧电线。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。